uh you have an amazing resume and and a
lot of the films you've done have gotten
critical acclaim and everyone's seen
them but there has to be like one or two
that you feel like that have fallen
through the cracks that maybe deserve
another look um what film or films would
you like to sort of stick like you know
a signal out if you will for like maybe
people to take another look at
uh
well my personal favorite i've made a
hundred films in my
christmas past
uh
my personal favorite that i'd love
people to take another look at it was
michael collins
jordan wrote and directed
um he was
for those that don't know he was an
irish revolutionary hero
one of the founders of the modern irish
state highly controversial
because he's regarded controversial
because he's regarded as the father of
modern day terrorism
even just saying that makes it
controversial
he invented the sales of people three
people two people three people four
people all fighting for the same cause
but each cell doesn't know what the
others doing
to cut down on informers
that was michael collins invented that
and it was adopted uh during the
formation of the state of israel for
example
anakin beggan and his colleagues they
all had code words for their operations
uh some of which were in honor of
michael collins to be called mikhail
for certain operations
that's a film i i i don't think many
people saw it in this country you know
uh
it did very well in ireland of course
before titanic
game that
put it into second place or third place
you know but uh that that film i'd love
for people to
see again you know
you've done as you mentioned a hundred
roles
of those hundred
what's like the one or two that you
really went above and beyond in like
your preparation process in terms of
getting ready to make the the project
well uh certainly michael collins um
oh there's been two or three others but
i think this uh memory film was alex
lewis character
i did quite a lot of research especially
on the field of
the affliction of alzheimer's and
dementia
which my character
in memory is suffering from you know
and it gives the script
and the
film
uh
various levels of moral ambiguity let's
say you know what i was going to say one
of the things about memory um and your
performance in the film is a lot of
stars if you will
um
you know sometimes they debate showing
themselves as like weaker on screen you
know i've heard stories about certain
action stars refuse to lose a fight
in a movie and what i enjoy which i i
guess is true but what i enjoyed about
this is that you are willing to portray
someone who's not the strongest in the
room who's being afflicted with an
ailment that affects millions of people
um can you is that one of the reasons
why you wanted to make this project
well absolutely absolutely yeah yeah
yeah i i know some actors to refuse to
lose a fight or
you know and i get it i get it
but uh no i'm not from that stable
um
i i love showing a character's
vulnerability uh
especially if he's been made to be
an action hero or something like that
you know
you know
as a kid i did love westerns i love this
strong silent stoical type
but the older i got and the more i i've
been i had the luck to be in this
profession it's like
no it's good to show you know we're all
we're all shades of grey you know we're
all we've all got strengths and we've
all got weaknesses and that's it's
important for an audience to
to to to see that you know
uh completely um you got to work with
martin campbell and i've spoken to
martin before and i know he takes a real
interest in action scenes and he's
always going for the realism
and he likes to shoot them a particular
way
um can you sort of talk about
collaborating with him and what did you
enjoy about working with him martin's
old school uh by that i mean he's the
type of director he's the governor on
set you know
and uh which i like i like having my
boss
be the director my director being the
boss
but that being said we we worked very
closely because i
from my research into the alzheimer's
dash dementia
i
i wanted to
my character to show little traits of
this than the other
and but i you know i said tomorrow like
i said martin if i'm going overboard
with this and i'm showing too much of
this particular aspect please pull me
back you know which he did
uh so we worked very closely and i i
totally left the action up to him
because he is he's a master of it you
know
and he always keeps in mind
the thrust and the dynamism of the
storyline you know which is very
important
some directors would get bogged down in
one one aspect of a scene and then
it loses the kick the the momentum of
the film of the story you know
but martin's always keeps the
the shape of the film in his head you
know
so no he was great to work with martin
i'd love to work with him again one of
the things i found amusing is that in
the film your character is writing
things down on his arm to remember and
of course guy pierce is in this movie
from memento who spends the entire movie
you know tattooing himself and writing
things down so he'll remember uh i just
found that you know uh amusing funnily
enough i hadn't seen memento even though
i've worked with chris nolan who
directed memento
um
i did watch it before we started working
the film i thought he was fantastic i
only knew guy from like la confidential
on
uh i'm very proud to say his new friend
and uh terrific actor i think he really
roots the whole film for me i have a
memory
um
guy uh
monica bellucci two wonderful wonderful
actors
uh very easy on the eye as well
uh it's just terrific really these these
are real pros do you know what i mean
real professionals
uh yeah it was a joy to work with you
know completely it's one of the reasons
i was interested in seeing the movies
when you have actors of this caliber i'm
like oh and martin campbell of course i
want to watch this and i want to help
promote it uh when i last spoke to you
um you had recently wrapped on marlow i
think um so i'm just curious have you
actually seen a rough cut of it
um
yes i did i saw i've seen more than a
rough cut in fact i saw it just two
nights ago
um
it's still a work in progress but it's
it's
pretty unique and appears
a homage to raymond chandler
to the marlow character you know
wonderfully
played by bob mitchum robert mitchum and
bogart of course
um
not that i
emulate them at all we've we've
but it's uh you know uh wonderful
jessica langs in it diane krueger
uh alan [ __ ] we've got a wonderful
cast you know so i was very pleased to
see it it's again it's not finished
but uh enough
it's certainly a slot you know
uh and we shot it in uh barcelona and
dublin that was
that was standing in for los angeles
1937.
if you could believe it
um
that was a joy and it was great to work
with neil again we've done four films
together
and i've known neil for like over 40
years now so
uh he's terrific he just gets better and
better but but marlo
is i it's a good film it's good i'm very
much looking forward to it and uh uh
william monahan told me why they filmed
in spain for los angeles and about the
architecture and it still looks a
certain way i'm i'm very excited to see
it um i'm out of time i just want to say
congrats and it's always a great day
when i get to talk to you thank you so
much for your time oh youtube man thank
you
you